politique le plus drôle de France on
sait qui c'est pour le monde batterie
Fabien Roussel le pape il a remporté le
Grand Prix de l'Humour en politique 2022
pour une petite phrase prononcée en mars
dernier sur TF1 sur les prix des
carburants on écoute c'est très court
mais c'est très drôle
la station d'essence c'est le seul
endroit où on tient le pistolet et on se
fait braquer
pas mal pas mal le prix du jury est
attribué à Nicolas Sarkozy qui avait des
carreaux au point et ça pour moi pour
moi c'est la meilleure c'est pas parce
que tu achètes de la peinture une toile
et des pinceaux que tu deviens Picasso
Valérie Pécresse elle a pris mes idées
mon programme et elle a fait 4,8%
Édouard Philippe on a également reçu un
prix pour sa phrase à propos de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il faut une certaine audace
pour que quelqu'un qui a été battu à une
élection où il était candidat puisse
penser qu'il serait élu à une élection
il n'est pas chronique et puis je
conclus aller avec Anne Hidalgo citation
tirée du livre de Gaspard Glaser tous
les matins je me lève en disant que tout
le monde m'aime ah oui elle est
drôlement elle est tellement drôle qu'on
l'a gardé pour la fin parce que c'est
pas loin d'être la meilleure Benjamin
Marine Le Pen a le sourire en ce moment
ah bon ouais et pourquoi pas
il y a des nuits interminables
à l'heure hôtel de Doha les Marocains
savourent ce moment suspendu historique
à quelques kilomètres de là au souk de
la ville les supporters embrasent les
rues le Maroc est désormais la quatrième
sélection du continent africain à se
hisser en quart de finale de Coupe du
monde
[Applaudissements]
parlons si vous voulez bien du Maroc de
la victoire de du Maroc hier qui est
très intéressant d'ailleurs d'abord on
salue cette qualité de victoire c'est la
première fois que les Marocains sont
finales en quart de finale d'une Coupe
du monde mais c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
quelques petites débordements disons-le
quelques vous ne parlez que les
débordements
c'est ça le but de de votre exerg c'est
bien un français un charcutier français
qui est devenu champion d'Europe de la
saucisse grillée il s'appelle Jérôme
Chauveau charcutier traiteur installé
dans la petite commune de baie en
Mayenne opposée à des dizaines de
concurrents s'associe ça suce séduire le
jury grâce dit-il sa sauce la société
assez d'huile jury avec de bons produits
qui permettent de se démarquer des
industriels utiles non j'ai une
invitation pour finir tu veux mon zizi
Vincent qui vient d'être chevalier fait
Chevalier des Arts et des Lettres oui
oui
tu as gardé le les pommes que j'ai
mangées manger tu l'écris comment et à
la fin
et s ah oui et es ces erreurs sont très
voire trop fréquentes le niveau en
orthographe des élèves de CM2 continuent
même de baisser sur la même dictée ils
font 19 fautes là où les élèves de 1987
en faisait 10 Elizabeth prise encore en
flagrant délit de récidive de récidive
de récidive de vapotage à l'Assemblée
nationale c'était hier petit vapotage
discretose derrière le masque parce que
oui il portait tous le masque hier à
l'Assemblée on s'en fout ou pas je
rappelle il est interdit de vapoter que
ce soit au Sénat au Palais Bourbon sur
les lieux de travail on conseille des
ministres on l'avait vu aussi vapoter à
côté d'enfance est interdit c'est 35
euros d'amende est-ce qu'on s'en fout ou
pas
pardon GG demande un rappel à l'ordre
que madame la Première ministre
solennelle par madame la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale il est interdit de
vapoter sur le lieu de travail nous
c'est très très large
on va se mettre tous à cloper
effectivement
ce bâtiment en 2017 Emmanuel Macron
investit l'Élysée où il était
visiblement pressé
et pour loger dans ce 100 mètres carrés
en plein cœur du 8e arrondissement
le présidentiel paierait bien son loyer
pour la somme de
2153 euros
fois bien moins que la valeur du marché
une information qui a choqué de nombreux
Français j'ai bien entendu sérieux même
25000 ne serait pas assez pour un tel
palais je me demande parfois monsieur le
Président si vous ne nous prenez pas
pour des blinblins comme on dit sur les
champs de course chantal Ladesou nous
empêche de vieillir elle ce soir notre
invité on en a bien besoin
[Musique]
pardon mais ça m'arrive tout le temps
c'est tout est dangereux
soyez la bienvenue priorité au direct à
Pauline de Mallet a oublié la grande
Apoline
en quittant la matinée après son
interview avec Madame panier
[Rires]
le prix du Pass Navigo le nouveau passe
Navigo est enfin fixé oui il y a eu des
semaines de tergiversation finalement et
bien ça y est l'abonnement mensuel vous
coûtera au final à partir du mois
prochain 84 route 10 une hausse
d'environ 12% et sachez que le ticket de
métro à l'unité lui évoluera il passera
de 1,90 € à 2 euros 10 c'est l'État qui
a renforcé son aide tiens puis pour des
bonnes nouvelles et ben ne venez pas
chez nous voilà